good morning
Millennials welcome back to the toast
and happy hump day hope everybody's
having a blessed day don't forget to
hump someone you love today and there's
no greater segue than that the girl that
I love there never is I can't believe
it's Wednesday in some ways it feels
like a long week and in some ways it
feels like a short week and I feel like
the week is going by and I don't have
enough time but on the other hand I woke
up today I'm like it could be Thursday
it really could be maybe it should be
maybe if people cared it would be
Thursday
maybe if people cared about Thursday you
would know what it's like for you to
wake up and it not be Thursday to me it
Feels Like Sunday because I have lived a
thousand lives since we last spoke to
you all on this podcast mainly I watched
what is probably the most disturbing
documentary I've ever seen wow what and
I'm gonna I'm going to call someone out
because I only heard about the
documentary on Remy Bader's Instagram
and Remy the fact that I had to watch
this I blame you for you should be
deplatformed for putting this out in the
universe okay did did she tell you to
watch it did she recommend it or she
just mentioned it just mentioned that it
was wild and then I saw it somewhere
else on Tik Tok I'm like oh this is
clearly something people are talking
about let me watch it now I watched you
with Ben and Ben is mad at me so
therefore if a equals b and b equals c
Ben is also mad at Remy Bader he doesn't
know it yet but he
is and let me I just need to say that
nobody should watch this
documentary and people had said Claudia
you're not going to believe the turn
that it takes and I didn't I didn't
believe the turn that it takes now I
won't spoil it but it's about this cult
and it wasn't a very successful cult but
it was interesting because they were
like you know digital they Liv streamed
their entire day 24/7 so there was so
much footage and essentially the cult
leader as all good cult leaders do
believe believed that she was
God
and was she no they were all doing drugs
you know and drinking 24/7 non-stop for
like 15 years and and this you know
mother God they called her this leader
her real name was Amy she pretty much
drunk herself to
death she also had anorexia and she was
really like believed that the smaller
the weight she was she would Ascend
higher to Heaven you know making her
lighter so we saw it's giving math we
saw this woman Jackie for probably the
last two years of her life drink herself
to death and so all the footage she's
getting smaller and smaller she's
getting more decrepit and more decrepit
and because she's like very spiritual
she is not taking any medicine they
don't believe in 3D doctors 3D is what
we would call reality and so she just
drinks these tinctures of basically
metal and she turns blue she's gray and
then by the very end she is blue and I
was shook that like I mean I guess that
for most of it she was still alive but
like I would say for like the last
couple of weeks she was like a dead
person like but she had a pulse you know
she couldn't walk they were she wasn't
speaking they were putting her in the
bath this she wanted yes to ascend to
ascend I I couldn't believe what I was
watching like I will be haunted forever
what taunting about it like these are
people like nutty people making their
own choices to be
nutty what is haunted is the the
physical the visual of someone who is so
bones okay blue blue Jackie she was blue
I swear to God it looked like paint she
was blue and then when she actually died
her followers kept her body in a hotel
room for a few days and they were like
doing all this like electromagnetic
they're like look she's stimulating
energy like and so we were just been
from all the metal she was that's what
Ben was saying she was magnetic so they
took these like devices up to her foot
and they're like look it's going up I'm
like gu she's literally a statue she
metal she's filled with metallic then
the hotel was getting suspicious so they
took her body out into the woods and
we're like waiting for the Ascension
they they thought this like you know was
it a nice hotel no no they didn't have a
lot of money but they were like doing a
lot of live streams selling that metal
product those tinctures to people um
lots of products you know doing booking
sessions for
healing I will never in my life get that
visual out of my
head the the documentary starts with a
picture of this like alien body that's
how the police discovered this body and
we're like I wonder where this alien
comes into play and then slowly over
time you realize like this woman who was
like a normal looking blonde lady then
Bernette is the alien becomes the alien
Jackie me and Ben we could not believe
what we were watching like it was fak
show at its finest it was all live
streamed there was so much to unpack
like the Dr Phil of it all but for me
like I and they had people who are a
part of the cult in the documentary
they're still very much but like Amy and
is God they were crying about her death
they you know some of them went back to
their normal lives but some of them
still there was this one lady who was so
this was just like what people weren't
saying this was a group of mentally ill
people and one of the people who was in
my opinion the most brainwashed she had
showed up all these people like found
Amy online were they mentally ill when
they arrived or they became mentally ill
both they were susceptible they were
vulnerable okay
and but they they were all mentally ill
like it's like some of the stuff that
they were saying it was just beyond and
this one woman who I think was probably
the most vulnerable she all these people
found Amy online and Amy you know
invited them to join so they all like
lived in this cabin they were always
moving and this one woman joined and
brought her four
kids yeah and it was it was a cracked in
like they were they were it's not like
okay you want to be wooy wooy hippie
like sit in the grass harmless but they
were all doing drugs no that's child
abuse yeah and the lady's mom did
eventually come pick up up the kids and
she didn't see them for many years and
she was like it's really tough but like
this is what mother God wants um she was
like the most vulnerable and she's still
like she was crying when she was telling
the story about mother God dying like it
like I don't I don't even know I don't
even know please do not watch this
documentary like it was really upsetting
well it sounds like you kind of like
gave away the ending anyway like the
alien is Amy and she goes blue D and I
just want to say that for me was the was
that her name was that the name of the
documentary blueo I just want to say one
of my takeaways from the documentary and
I don't think this was many takeaways
from the from for many people like the
people of Hawaii will not be with
like when she was dying they were like I
got a call from the galactics
oh one of the core tenants of this cult
is that like Robin Williams poisly like
is a part of this cult he's one of the
leaders he speaks to Mother God and
mother God tells him his message so
they're like Robin said we have to go to
Hawaii does Robin know did Robin know he
was a part of this cult or he's just
kind of like someone that they've you
know that's a good question because the
the cult spans many years and I'm sure
one of those years is when Robin
Williams
died yeah H I don't know they didn't
bring it up but Robin Williams said we
have to go to Hawaii so they take this
woman who literally is blue cannot walk
is Skin and Bones they can put her on a
plane okay they got to Hawaii and like
the in Kawai the local people start to
figure out that there's this woman
claiming she God and they're very
spiritual people that they're all living
in this house and then it becomes like a
thing in the community people start
protesting and then she really angers
Everyone by saying I am I'm sorry I
don't remember the name they have this
God of of nature or something it's
really like a very powerful important
person in the Hawaii Community and she
says I am her oh my God Blasphemous they
run this woman out of town they get her
out like no one has in Colorado in
Oregon they've never been able to like
crack the the police know about her
there's nothing they can do people of
Hawaii got her out in weeks like do not
with the people of Hawaii
yeah it was so dumb please don't watch
it wasn't gonna never heard of it
certainly not tempted now but um thanks
for the
synopsis oh my God oh my God I
I yeah I'm not
okay what was it called love has won cuz
that was the name of their call
LW that's really a bad cult name yeah
that's how you know that's how you know
I think the making of a good cult
documentary is when they have former
members okay and who can really who are
now out of it and can see how nutty it
was and there were only two people in
the documentary who left the cult but
they still like spoke about it with
reverence and like I don't know it
wasn't they didn't go hard enough for me
you know yeah because if everybody's
still in the cult for the most most part
and there's no one who's trying to get
just like who needs Justice here no one
it's just kind of like a bunch of freaks
doing their thing yeah I guess it was a
victimless crime yeah and so when no
one's like there's no actionable items
no one's upset about what's going on the
one person who died is the person who
started it and she wanted to die she
chose to it's hard to become move to
action when there's nothing to be done
and like sometimes true you got to let
your freak flag fly and everybody's
looks different they let their Fleek
freak flag fly a little too close to the
Sun though I feel like freak is one of
those words that's going to get canceled
soon oh interesting and so I've got to
use it as much as I can or it's the
opposite I have to stop so that they
can't find old footage but before it's
like you know part of the cancellation
the group freak freak freak freak for
freak freak that's a good call but no
sometimes freak is the best word I feel
like freak was an integral word in our
childhood like oh she's a freak freaky
like freak I don't know if it was like a
family thing or it was a cultural thing
at the time like when we were all people
our age were you guys also like saying
freak all the time and we need to make
it make freak cool again like we need to
bring it back we do need to bring it
back but then so many things would be
canceled if it was canceled one Freaky
Friday the movie that was a freaky film
the song but by Chris Brown right I woke
up in Chris Brown's
Body oh yeah I think that song is
already canceled for different reasons
having nothing to do with the language
you know no I don't think so the
celebrities were in the video yeah but
now I think we all as a culture look
back on that and they say why was
Kendall Jenner in a Chris Brown music
video right at least I do I thought it
at the time cuz I'm better than
everybody else also Victor Justice
Victoria is Freak the Freak Out she did
a double
freak what I'm going to do now is Freak
the freak the soundtrack of that
incredibly dumb show had absolutely no
business popping off in the way that it
did there were so many songs no and
that's how I feel about a lot of Disney
music Nickelodeon music like those
songwriters where are they now who wrote
The Climb and what have they done since
because I'll that person is
Beethoven agreed the Beethoven of our
time even like Kenny
Ortega how come there how come he never
ascended okay it was written by someone
named Jesse Alexander okay
she has had her songs recorded by Trisha
Yearwood Little Big Town she's very
country of course that's why it's good a
most recent um
song I I I don't know many of
these The Climb is definitely her
biggest her most recent song was for
Midland Sunrise tells the story I should
go and listen to all the songs that
she's worked on I'm sure I would love
them you should
oh oh she wrote um
it sounds a little bit like my daddy I
don't cuss around my mama got some words
never heard he come from down y That's
by Morgan Wallen that's a song I that's
I think maybe the only song I know of
hers besides all of these others and
she's a woman yes it's a androgynous
name yes but only a woman could write a
song as beautiful as the climb like for
real agreed it's um it's from a woman's
voice we have such a great show today
cuz we have dear toaster we have an
update from a somewhat recent one that
kind of divided the community okay we
also have Time person of the year which
I really and I have something insane to
say we have a lot to break down from her
first sitdown interview in four years
very long article did you read the whole
thing I don't think so I did read the
whole thing maybe I was almost at the
bottom when I gave up but I got the
juice uh and I have something to say
about the article so I'm ready to dive
in okay so without further there a d do
about someone who was BL do doo here are
the fast High stories that you need to
know mother God was giving
Bluey is bluee blue yes the
dog is it a dog it's a cartoon like it's
a little
caricature no but he's a dog right I
don't know I don't watch but I know that
he's
blue I feel like I've watched more than
you Bluey I watched it with Kayla he
might be a blue dog
yeah he's blue he's blue confirmed blue
is blue maybe he was inspired by mother
God herself maybe it's kind of a
subliminal message to make people join
lhw and they're are you saying it's
propaganda they're indoctrinating the
children bluee is a cult
leader blue is a cult leader no you know
who's a cult leader us Mickey
Mouse yeah yeah Olivia sent me the
funniest like blog about why Mickey
Mouse is one of the Kim jongs and how
like the way that he runs Mickey Mouse
Clubhouse like it's North Korea let me
just read this one quote and you okay
and you'll know exactly what I'm saying
is the article saying that Mickey Mouse
is pushing like North Korean propaganda
or there's just a lot of similarities
he's he's inspired by supreme leader
that's what it is so amongst other
references that they cite and they do
have a theory that all of his friends
are being like kept under around in his
Clubhouse and they can't escape but for
sure Mickey Mouse is essentially a Kim
Jong they don't do exercise they do
Mousercise they don't use tools they use
Mouser tools they eat Mousa food they
breathe Mousa air they hang out in
Mickey Park they live in the Mickey
Mouse Clubhouse the password is Misa
Musa Mickey Mouse the entire Clubhouse
is an architectural nightmare Effigy of
Mickey himself Mickey is essentially the
dear leader of his own vanity fueled
Universe imagine how how the other
clubmates feel living in that world and
having and having to pretend they enjoy
it they are clearly
underdress yeah like there's like indiv
individuality is illegal in Mickey Mouse
land and that's true for North Korea as
well everything is a shrine to Mickey
Mickey
shaped everything I was in the book we
were reading last night there's a chair
and it looks like Mickey it's giving Kim
Jong-un yeah so that's just something
for you to chew on the next time you're
watching the next time you're eating
your Mousa food in the Mousa Clubhouse
all right well our stories are brought
to you by rettin raketen is the most
rewarding way to Shop and Save because
our members earn cash back on everything
that they buy rettin is a shopping
platform that partners with over 3700
stores across every category that
includes Beauty clothing Electronics
Home department stores pets Etc so
you're already shopping at your favorite
stores why not be saving money while
doing it it's truly a no-brainer we're
always shopping but this time of year
especially gifts for those you love for
thyself lots of money being spent this
year so shop smarter not harder with
reton it's the smartest way to save
money when you shop because you can
stack holiday sales on top of cashbacks
and maximize your savings you can shop
through rettin for everyone on your gift
list this holiday earn cash back on
clothing and shoes for a fashionista
toys and games for the little ones
electronics for your Tech connoisseur
the stories uh the stores pay rakitin a
commission for sending them Shoppers and
rettin shares that commission with its
members so you get paid via check or
PayPal quarterly they have 17 million
members who are already saving you can
get the free rettin app and download the
free browser extension they're going to
find you the best deals sales and
coupons they're doing all the work for
you at amazing Brands like Macy's Adidas
Walmart Nike Bloomingdales blue Mercury
YSL Beauty wine.com Samsung Sephora
Keels tot Cosmetics Fenty Beauty Dyson
if you're treating yourself to a Dyson
air app this season be smart cuz that
thing will uh cost you a mortgage so
download the rackon app for free
download the uh browser extension that's
also for free and just start shopping
you know start shopping start saving
this holiday season today's episode is
also brought to you by Squarespace the
all-in-one website platform for
entrepreneurs to stand out and succeed
online whether you're just starting out
or managing a growing brand Squarespace
makes it easy to create a beautiful
website engage with your audience and
sell anything from products to content
to time all in one place all on your
terms so whatever reason you might have
for wanting to start a website or maybe
revamp your website whether you have a
side hustle you work in e-commerce you
own a small business Squarespace is the
place to go CU it can be very
overwhelming and kind of intimidating to
build a website like some people
literally go to like trade school for
that no we just have Squarespace and
it's so easy so if you want to you know
showcase an asset Library like if you're
a photographer a videographer an artist
a graphic designer who wants to show
like a portfolio of work you can upload
organize and access all your content
from one place you can sell custom merch
you can Showcase Video collections their
website templates are really flexible so
get started with with one of the website
templates they look very professional
they have designs for every category and
then you'll be able to customize your
look update your content and add
features that fit your unique needs what
I love most is especially if you're
using Squarespace for e-commerce and you
also want to sell in person whether
you're doing like a trade show or
something they have a point of sale so
you can sell in person by connecting a
square reader to the Squarespace app
it'll keep your orders your inventory
and your customer data in sync with your
online store so everything will be
organized and clean just for you so
check out Squarespace head to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com toast to save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or a
domain that's squarespace.com
toast today's episode is also brought to
you by the game time app you should not
have to worry about when to buy tickets
for your next big event game time is the
fast and easy way to buy tickets for all
the sports music comedy and theater near
you with killer last minute deals all in
pricing and views from your seats plus
their best price guad aned game time
takes the guesswork out of buying
tickets so game time is the only
ticketing app that gives you complete
piece of mind with your purchase see the
view from your seat before you buy so
you know exactly what to expect when you
arrive they're all in prices show you
your total upfront so you know what
you're getting and that you're getting a
great deal before you check out nothing
worse than like scouring finding
decently priced tickets then going to
check out and it's actually double the
price because of fees game time is going
to show you the actual price up front
you can buy tickets in seconds with two
Taps the app is very easy to use um they
have tickets on they have deals on
tickets right up to the start of the
event even an hour after it starts so
you can find exclusive Flash Deals and
sponsor deals on tickets for football
basketball baseball concerts comedy
theater and more with Zone deals you'll
pick the section and game time will pick
the seats for Big Time Savings and of
course the game time guarantee means
you'll always get the best price if you
find tickets somewhere else in the same
section and row for Less game time will
credit you 110% of the difference so
take the guess workk out of buying
tickets with Game Time download the game
time app create an account and use code
toast for $20 off your per your first
purchase terms apply again create an
account redeem code toast for $20 off
that's t o a s download game time today
last minute ticket deals lowest price
Guan great thank you our first story of
the Year times person of the year our
first story of the day times person of
the year is here and after much debate
by us yesterday over the finalists they
decided it should be Taylor Swift I have
so many questions about the process
because it's clear in the interview this
process is month long starting in the
summer they were in Santa Clara for that
show there like kind of evaluating her
for person of the year um the year like
wasn't even halfway over but very
interesting I wonder if they do sort of
this with everybody who's nominated and
then pick a winner and everybody else
gets like a little blurb elsewhere
that's fair um so I have a lot to say
okay the first thing I want to say is I
told you so like I knew this was going
to be it and it's so major you know the
second thing I want to say is very crazy
and and very
controversial I think there's a chance
that Taylor Smith listens to the
toast I did not have a dissimilar
thought okay because she said two things
now the first wasn't didn't raise my
eyebrows that much she used the word
nefarious we didn't invent that word
it's a word we definitely use it more
than other people our age it's something
that's associated with us but we by no
means invented it no and it's definitely
a word for the reason that we love it
it's also a word that she would love too
because it's very aith it's
descriptive you know exactly it it's
punchy so I could see her separately
parallel thinking arriving at the same
word then she said something else I saw
what she said and when she was asked
about
Beyonce she was explaining why she loves
Beyonce and how Beyonce is just a
precious gem of a
person I
I rest my case I saw that too and then
it got me going back to be like where
and when did we start saying that like
we've been saying that since 2018 at
least did we get it from something that
maybe she got it from like it resonated
with her too or did we totally make that
up I don't even know what's our did we
invent precious gem of a man or a woman
I feel I don't know I can't think of a
reference of like a movie or somewhere
where we got it
from yeah yeah and the thing is with the
toast like you can you know deny that
you listen to it but based on the way
you talk like we'll be able to tell you
know also the trash takes itself out yes
oh my God yes yeah no we didn't invent
that no and we didn't say like that we
said that we were going to take the
trash out also trash taking itself out
when does that happen you got to take
out your trash yeah no I just think I
know we sound crazy
I think there's a chance I I had like a
split second of a thought I was like oh
she sounds like toasty but I didn't
actually think maybe she listens but
then one more thing what she heard
Travis's podcast about her so she's not
unfamiliar with the act of listening to
a podcast she's not unfamiliar with the
medium she's
not I just wanted to say that I think
it's possible now I know I'm delusional
but I actually don't think that she
could listen listen to our podcast
because of how much we talk about her
even though most of it's positive I
wouldn't want to hear people talk about
me every single day and like with the
and probably half of more than half of
what we say and theorize about her is
wrong and that'd be really frustrating
like her screaming at the podcast like
no we started dating way long ago that
wasn't our hard launch at the first
game I just think there's a chance and I
wanted to say that okay now so many
other things to take away from the
article it was really well done and she
hasn't done like a full-blown sit down
interview like no holds bar in a really
long time and there were a lot of
interesting things that I noted I think
I saw people you know I think a lot of
people are like getting tired of hearing
about Kanye and Scott boretta and
scooter and like I I understand what
people say when they're like it's like
enough already but I also do understand
the notion like this is her Roman Empire
you know and and what I really
appreciated the journalist being like is
the way Taylor talks about how she lost
everything before reputation like she
didn't leave her house her career was
taken from her from the you know the
consumer POV like yeah it was a scandal
but I never thought like Taylor wasn't
coming back from it you know she bounced
back with reputation and it was just as
big if not bigger so the art the author
was like I was going to say that but
like I'm not going to invalidate her
experience like this happened to her and
that's how she she processed it but I
felt the same way like I never really
thought of it as like this Monumental
thing but for Taylor and her experience
it was and I understand not being able
to stop talking about something that
happened to you like I really do yeah
yeah and on the one hand it was like
okay it's a scandal move on but on the
other hand like there was something
about it that really upended
everything about her Persona yeah like
it was very big yes for her and it
changed the way a lot of people thought
about her and felt about her time
yes yeah but it's always that hindsight
thing like after a scandal in the moment
you're like ah yeah and then years later
you're like who cares but I also think
her reaction to it made it bigger like
she said she stayed at home for a year
you know yes making it if she had just
sort of like even put something out and
like went back and forth with them it it
would have kept moving but it we all
Stood Still in it for a year until she
came back with like in a Revenge album
which made it even bigger um still at
the
restaurant still sitting in the corner I
haunt like she didn't move she didn't
move so none of us could move on yeah
yeah that's true and I also just did
really appreciate she said something so
true it's
like the music industry just throws like
young girls into the spotlight and
sometimes it hits and they're never old
enough to really understand process
protect themselves and by the time they
get to an age where they're like ready
for it they're tossed out like you know
yesterday's trash and new young girls
are brought in so she's like the fact
that I'm experiencing this undeniable
Peak when I'm old enough to understand
it to deal with it and like process it
is so crazy yeah I thought that was
really smart too especially after just
reading Britney Spears's book it's like
by the time well she never really got
the hang of the industry just cuz she's
not cut out for it like not Cutthroat
like you know just too naive and sweet
um but by the time you figure it out
you're out of the game right so the fact
that you is it intentional because it's
like they don't want you to have it
figured out but also they don't want you
to be old right 29 is not old no but the
fact that she's like conscious of living
in a peak right now she said I'm like
the strongest and most trusting I've
ever been like I can handle what's going
on right now like that was so cool yeah
no you can enjoy it instead of being
like so fearful and also or being so I
feel like this happens to some artists
where they're so successful they're
touring they're making huge hits but
they are in shitty contracts where
they're not actually making close to the
amount of money that they should like
she can she's making all the money for
herself like she can enjoy The Spoils of
her success it's a it's a great
time um and then I screenshotted this
part obviously she was asked about
Travis so given her complex history with
public interest in her dating life I say
it seems noteworthy that her
relationship with Kelsey has played out
so publicly Swift gently pushes back
this all started when Travis very
adorably put me on blast on his podcast
which I thought was metal as hell she
says we started hanging out right after
that like a boomer what does that mean
metal is hell I don't know I think it
means like like so rockstar I think okay
I think we started hanging out right
after that so we actually had a
significant amount of time that no one
knew which I'm grateful for because we
got to know each other
when when would did per Rock the stage
at Arrow when she rocked the stage I
don't know I can't even search Taylor
s's Arrowhead now by the time I went to
that first game we were a couple I think
some people think that that was our
first date at the game we would never be
Psy otic enough to hard launch at a
first date the larger point for her is
that there's nothing to hide when you
quote when you say a relationship is
public that means I'm going to see him
do what he loves we're showing up for
each other and other people are there
and we don't care she says quote the
opposite of that is that you have to go
to an extreme amount of effort to make
sure no one knows that you're seeing
someone and we're just proud of each
other that's a swipe for
sure yeah that's a swipe right that's
why I screenshot it up yeah that's a
swipe at Mr comping notoriously
notorious L
private for a relationship it's also her
saying even though you guys pick up on
it through her music it's her saying
like that's not what I wanted for a
relationship right no I loved this I my
only issue with this entire feature is
that the photos were gorgeous I
especially loved the one with the cat it
was very funny her bangs were up the
whole time and I think like Taylor
Swifts bangs are a core it's a
Cornerstone of her brand they've carried
us through I really feel that way and
for them to just kind of blow dry them
up into her hairline like I thought was
disrespectful and like you can't capture
the essence of Taylor Smith without her
iconic bangs her bangs her bangs there's
one photo with bangs with um the hair in
her face do you see it scroll down
you're covering it no no no I'm not I
just
here yeah okay but there were I'm
talking about the covers there were
three different covers and the bangs
were up in all of them I didn't know you
were so into the bangs and attached to
the bangs I I mean it's Taylor Swift
coded I guess so I never thought too
much about her bangs like this is her
kind of this is like a lifetime
achievement thing like you want her to
look like herself yeah they didn't
really do that they tried like new
stylish artistic which
um not like necessary like it should be
like a
portrait agreed but that's also me being
very literal and but I am a literal
person you are I'm not like artistic
abstract whatsoever I'm very right side
like I want portrait maybe even
by an art I don't know Ellen Von nworth
Annie Lebovitz love maybe like a she's
naked from the back and she's wearing a
sheet across her bosom and she's turned
side very Miley Cyrus Vanity Fair like
that's what that's what it should have
been yeah so all in all I love this and
especially I'm glad we went through all
the people who have won in previous
years because noting how few music
creative art people have won makes this
like a an even bigger deal because it
really is a global thing yes I agree and
I still can't think of one person who
when we looked at the list yesterday
who's comparable in winning so this is
kind of like a first yeah it's major it
is Major so I wonder what they do with
all the other interviews of the other do
they always have an interview with the
star like if they had Putin as the
winner do they get a sit down that's a
good question can you interview Putin I
think so actually I just saw a Tik Tok
Megan Kelly was talking about the
craziest time of her life When She
interviewed Putin yeah I think but I
don't know if time would interview pu
Putin right that's a call Putin or like
or president she like does he want to
talk to Time Magazine right I'm gonna
say no because even though like for us
this is like the person of the year
Global like to them it's just like some
an American publication silly American
fodder yeah yeah well maybe that's why
they did tailor yeah so I'm here for it
and I think it's an accurate
representation of the
year I agree and I think they were able
to make this meteor by talking about
like the
economic effects and how it really you
know world domination and it's like why
are you going to give it to the Jerome
Powell when it's Jerome Powell's talking
about Taylor Swift effect right right
when all these world leaders are like
licking her boots yeah so I think that
they made it make sense and it it's very
it was well done it was well done and
well earned as well and fun for the fans
to get to hear from Taylor I think this
is probably one of the biggest
accomplishments for Taylor I don't think
really I mean even though she acts like
every award is so meaningful to her like
I think that this is something that
Above All Else yeah I also thought it
was interesting the people who time
chose to SP speak to like on her behalf
like of course they spoke to her mom
they spoke to Phoebe Bridgers I think
that um Phoebe Bridgers I like I know
you're not I'm not like a big fan either
but I think she's really um well
respected as a songwriter and I think
they wanted that to like shine through
for Taylor so I think that's why they
chose her Stevie
Nicks um Shonda
Rimes yeah um and I loved that little
Kenny chesy
anecdote oh yeah that's how it started
yeah but like she had been booked on
this Kenny Chesney tour and it was like
the biggest deal of her life she was G
she was like crying and then they
brought on a a company to be the sponsor
of the tour and Taylor was not 18 yet or
21 she was 17 she was 17 I think you
have to be 18 and she um lost the gig
and she was so upset and Kenny
Chesney like remembered that and like a
year or two later when she was 18 he
gave her the gig again and that's like
what started it all oh he gave her the
job yeah I thought he just gave her a
check oh wait in the article they said
they gave her a check and
okay hold on some months later she got
the gig at her 18th birthday she saw his
promoter he handed her a card from
chesne that read I'm sorry you couldn't
come on the tour so I wanted to make it
up to you with the note was a check it
was for more money than I'd ever seen in
my life I was able to pay my band
bonuses I was able to pay for my tour
buses I was able to fuel my
dreams oh wait it could be interpreted
either way I think he just gave her
money also I'm pretty sure at 18 you
still can't be with a liquor sponsor I'm
pretty sure you can't work with a liquor
sponsor until you're 25 until you're
25 yes um wait I miss I misunderstood
that that's even crazier he just gave
her a check yeah and then I was going to
ask you like how much do you think the
check was for um
$100,000 actually what year was it
inflation you know the economy 50
50,000 yeah that would pay for band
bonuses tour buses and fuel dreams 100
at least yeah because I think a tour bus
I think I read this somewhere once
actually I was like looking into doing
maybe a tour bus for my Comedy Tour once
is like a joke but it was like expensive
like a decent one is like 10 grand a
week okay so probably at least 10 eight
yeah six love Kenny Chesney oh I also
loved the Kelly Clarkson shout out of
course when she was talking about her
re-recording she was like you know
people would say it and like literally
every time I ran into Kelly Clarkson she
would tell me to re-record my music and
like my parents told me to do it but it
just felt like such a an undertaking I
wasn't sure if I was going to do it I
love that she always credits Kelly
Clarkson while it's like it's it's kind
of a parallel thinking idea it sound
like a unique idea that Kelly had
because other people in Taylor's life
told her to do it but I love that she
always credits Kelly right and also it
sounds like she ran into Kelly over the
years and Kelly continued to say to do
it yeah it was not just the Tweet we all
know about the Tweet but Taylor said I
would run into Kelly Clarkson and she
would always multiple always tell me to
do the re-recordings yeah our queen
queen queen matching Queen yeah so fun
Time person of the year always a fun
thing to talk about it's the end of the
year we have another uh of the year for
today's stories oh what is it it's at
the end okay I think it'll be a fun one
fast food chain of the year what is it
fast food chain of the year No but what
would be your fast food chain of this
year oh personal yeah well this was like
my year of health so like I actually
didn't eat a lot of fast food you know
what it would be for
us Sonic yes yeah the year we discovered
Sonic so good are you ready for our next
story yes it's a bit of an update from
yesterday's story about Amy and TJ
because now their exes Andrew Shu and
marily Le fig are dating after B Bonding
over the traumatic cheating
experience so the ex spouses of
scandalous news couple TJ Holmes and Amy
robach have gotten closer page six has
officially exclusively learned they are
dating according to multiple sources
we're told the couple have been dating
for about 6 months after bonding over
the experience of being cheated on quote
it turned into something else and
they're connected over their values it's
bigger than the affair now they're told
that the hurt is over and the duo has
moved on they're not heartbreaking and
sad heartbroken and sad they are moved
on this is like one of my favorite
romantic tropes it's giving Shai a Twain
a lot of thought immediately Shia
Twain's husband literally cheated on her
with her best friend and left her and
went with the best friend so Shania
ended up marrying the best friend's
ex-husband who also got left and they're
still together Wife Swap literally Wife
Swap what are other like classic
examples of that I don't think there
like Shia yeah but that would be like a
good book idea
yes and the thing is it's not really
that crazy of an idea cuz it's like if a
equals b and b equals C and C equals D
then a equals D it's logic because if
these two people could like liked aing
and Amy liked Brian or whatever his name
is it makes sense that the person who
once liked TJ through the transitive
property would like Brian it's a equals
D yes a equals b and b equals C and C
equals D then a equals D did I not just
say that oh did you I I missed the D
okay it's a equals
d by the way it makes complete logical
sense like all these people obviously
just have similar tastes right similar
interests they probably all values look
are they probably all on the same
category of looks yeah yeah they're all
good looking same league league league
yeah it should happen more often I would
say if you get cheated on the first
person you should try and call call for
if when you're ready for love is the
x that is so true and if it happened at
the like you guys got cheated on at the
same time you will both need the same
amount of time to grieve roughly to
grieve to get over it and then be ready
again your timeline your taxi cabs are
lining up
so true that's a silver lining
about getting cheated on but hopefully
you don't get cheated on with someone
single uh oh my God then it's like we're
all losers yeah yeah oh God hopefully
you get cheated on by I didn't even
think of that as like an an option I
think that happens a lot I think it most
is most of the time yeah damn so we
can't help you there no are you ready
for our next story
yeah Paris Hilton is revealing uh one of
the heartbreaking reasons why she opted
for surrogacy okay so Paris Hilton is
doing a lot of press cuz her new show
Paris and love is out she did an
expansive interview with Romper and she
explained that she still has so much
PTSD from what she went through at
Utah's provoc Canyon school for troubled
youth so she said if I'm in a doctor's
office I get a shot anything I will
literally have a panic attack and I
can't breathe I just knew that would not
be healthy for me or the baby growing
inside of someone who has such high
anxiety so when she was at the school
she talked about in her book she was
like physically sexually and emotionally
and abused and they would subject her to
gynecological exams against her will and
like hold her down and oh my God so now
she has a fear of doctor rightfully so
and didn't think that she could go
through all of that pregnant oh I have
chills yeah well that's makes a lot of
sense yeah makes a lot of sense I still
think like one of the craziest things
parlan's ever done is like have a
full-blown kid and not even tell her mom
or her sister like and then I do it
again yeah oh
yeah and yeah she did it twice like
that's so iconic I know I did the
episode with Olivia when we announced
that she had a baby girl and her kids
are 11 months apart it's so amazing and
then she brought her home for the
holidays no upset and her name is London
and it's giving London Tipton who was
inspired by Paris
life imitating art imitating life life
imitating art imitating life exactly
exactly uh but I do think a lot of
people who don't know Paris like or what
she's about or read her book like were
probably like oh why did she just opt to
have a surrogate and right you know what
maybe she had been through M this is it
is that a memoir you would recommend yes
okay speaking of Memoirs we would
recommend I started Keenan's book
yesterday after we like decided it would
be the perfect thing to read and
it's it's not my it's not it's not for
me I'm going to finish it because I'm
like 20% in and it's short and I want to
reach my goal but I really feel
like exactly how he described it
yesterday as you know he's never really
opened up about what he's been through I
feel like he's still not opening up like
it's so it's so surface level that's a
risky run with a memoir and also I funny
though is that that article that I chose
yesterday like the the point of the
article was about him saying like I'm
going there I'm writing a memoir like
what this is the time to go there and by
the way maybe he does go there I'm
literally only maybe 20 25% in maybe
he's just glazing over his childhood
because you typically don't like the
childhood part of the Memoir but he was
a child not even going in Chron he's not
going in chronological order because
he's talking a lot about being a parent
and how you know he grew up like very
middle class so he like really struggles
with how to like give his kids stuff
because he grew up with you know not not
nothing but much less than he has now
and he doesn't want to spoil them so
it's not chronological he hasn't talked
about like SNL yet it's just like it's
really not
good that's disappointing I know
surprising overall it's not funny
disappointing and surprising given
everything we said yesterday about how
he is a writer he is funny he does have
an interesting story we don't know it I
don't hear his voice in there at all
like it's really um
it's it's not it's I'm not enjoying
it it happens but like I'm ready for the
juice you know yeah and in his in the
prologue he's like I'm gonna get to it
like he's met everyone Elon Musk Obama
like everyone's been on
SNL yeah
okay yep are you ready for our next
story what number is this four yes
Ariana Maddox will make her Broadway
debut as Roxy heart in Chicago and she
did not win Dancing with the Stars last
night no someone else won yeah I didn't
know anyone in the top four besides
Ariana and I didn't know the person who
won I've not heard his name before me
neither but um we won't spoil it and
also cuz I still don't know his name but
also because I don't want to spoil it I
thought a girl won really yeah hold on I
thought hold on
hold on oh my god oh Jason moraz was in
the top I didn't even know that I didn't
know he was on the
season yeah hold on oh
um okay wait you might be right yeah
because she kept coming up on my Tik Tok
and she was cute as a
button okay yeah it was girl yeah I'm
right I'm right I just saw like a
picture of the top four and there was
like I guess it's all men and women I
don't know
no it's okay okay well I certainly
didn't spoil it then yeah yeah I know I
guess we still don't know who's going to
win man or woman tune in to find out but
Ariana did not win that was the point
that was the point but she's winning
stays winning because she will be
playing Roxy har in a limited 8we run in
the long running hit Chicago she said
it's just the biggest dream come true I
can't believe this is real life I'm
going to cry can Ariana sing well she
studyed musical theater at Flagler
College and first moved to New York City
after graduation with hopes of Landing a
spot on the great white way she never
made it instead moved to LA where she
would go on to find famous Vander pump
rules I feel like all of the Vander pump
rule Stars can do something sing or act
or are interested in either medium yeah
they were all like models and actors
when we first met them yeah so this is a
role Lisa Rena has played Eric Jane has
played it's kind of like a reality star
role well in Britney's book she talks
about how she was offered it and she
turned it down and she regrets that um a
lot of reality stars have hit I saw the
great Nene Leaks on Broadway in
Cinderella oh yeah no but that's yeah
she was in Cinderella but that's
different but I don't know if I saw it
with her as the Fairy Godmother or FR
and dreser as the fair Fairy Godmother I
remember I saw an iconic Fairy Godmother
but I can't remember if I'm conflating
two different stories now well that's a
real Broadway role like Nene's hor into
acting was very real this is like Buzzy
yes and I feel like it's always someone
of note who would be good at in the role
it's so crazy I don't think as a society
we talk enough about how real houses of
Atlanta shot Nene Leaks to such stardum
that she actually at one point left the
show and lived in LA because she was
getting so many legitimate acting roles
she was a huge role on Glee Ro Wasington
Roz Washington then she was in that
other show the new normal yeah she was
like that was kind of her show she was
like a Ryan Murphy gal kind of how like
Kim is now like a Ryan Murphy groupy we
know Emma Roberts he Sarah Paulson he
has like a group of girls he loves Nene
Leaks was one of them what happened I
don't know I mean Ross Washington is one
of the greatest characters in cinematic
history it's true she's this insane swim
coach at the local high school in GL
she's the only one who could take on Sue
Sylvester yes R Washington like so good
so good take me back she's in a lot of
stuff
yeah I wonder why she turned back home
why it didn't work out I wonder if she
had like a falling out with Ryan cuz
yeah he uses like Emma Roberts is in
everything he does like that could have
been for years he loves leam
Michelle okay so she was in Dynasty by
the way she was episode okay I was going
to say I've seen every episode a lot of
reality stars are like on their IMDb are
in things like as themselves yeah so she
was on The New Normal 22 Episodes she
was on 13 episodes of
Glee and that's really it Uncle Drew I
don't know that one that's not a Ryan
Murphy production I wonder what
happened I wonder what happened to are
you ready for our fifth and final story
no no the fifth and final story is
brought to you by L'Oreal the new
L'Oreal Paris bright reveal dark spot
serum and broadspectrum SPF 50 daily
lotion dark spots game over dark spots
are like the most annoying thing on the
planet you need to prevent them you need
to you know take care of them and
L'Oreal has a Duo two fabulous products
to treat them and then to prevent them
so first we we got to be wearing
subblock under our makeup girlies like
we absolutely need to and I know a lot
of people don't like to do it because
they leave a white cast and like your
makeup looks weird but not the
broadspectrum spf50 daily lotion from
L'Oreal it will protect you from the Sun
you know dark spots are intensified by
the Sun it is lightweight and a non-
greasy product it is a sunscreen that
has an invisible texture so it will
blend seamlessly with all with your skin
tone and it primes really well with
makeup put it on under your makeup and
just stop start listening to me then you
know life happens you will get some dark
spots that's why you got to try the
L'Oreal Paris bright revealed dark spot
serum after 12 weeks you can see up to
40% less visible less visibility on
post- acne marks 43% less visibility on
dark spots and 49% more even tone in one
week it will start fading even the most
stubborn of dark spots and after 2 weeks
your skin will look clearer your skin
texture will look refined and smooth
it's made for all skin tones it's
suitable for sensitive skin and it's
formula validated by dermatologist so
discover the new bright revealed dark
spot Duo visit Target online and in
store to buy yours today those two
products are the L'Oreal Paris bright
reveal dark spot serum and then the
broadspectrum spf50 daily lotion today's
episode is also brought to you by seed
seed's DS1 daily symbiotic is a
broadspectrum probiotic and Prebiotic
formulated with 24 clinically and
scientifically studied strains for Whole
Body Benefits including gut skin and
heart health everyone's talking about
gut health gut Mania gut gut gut gut gut
what can you actually do feel like a lot
of people are talking about a lot of
things but everyone's talking about seed
the probiotic that actually works
because it is designed to survive your
digestive tract to actually start
working if you've taken a probiotic or a
Prebiotic and you haven't felt like it
does anything that's because a lot of
times it won't survive your digestive
tract seeds got that taken care of
there's also a lot of reasons why you
would want to take care of your gut
health start taking a probiotic or a
Prebiotic number one is digestion like
you don't feel like you're a regular
girly who's making big soft duties seeds
will take care of it a lot of your skin
issues can be connected to your gut
health seed can help with
that so visit seed.com toast and use
code toast to redeem 25% off your first
month of seeds DS1 daily symbiotic
that's seed seed.com toast and use code
toast just a great thing to add to your
morning routine every single morning
you'll start seeing results becoming
regular maybe your skin will clear up
your gut will be
it works amazing you're pooping every
day your body will feel great and it'll
become a non-negotiable in your everyday
routine so visit seed.com toast and use
code toast to redeem 25% off your first
month of seeds DS1 daily symbiotic
that's seed s d.com toast code toast t t
thank you seed for sponsoring today's
episode thank you tury for telling us
about seed sponsoring today's episode
it's been an absolute pleasure our fifth
and final story Oxford 2023 word of the
year is here and it is I think I know
Riz yes so I learned a lot yesterday
because I obviously I knew the word RZ
it's a kid it's a word that the kids use
it means like swag you like oh he's got
a lot of RZ it's comes from the word
deriv from the word
Charisma I didn't know that and it
actually makes me like the word a lot
more I love the word Charisma I think
it's a grossly underused term and it's
going to be continue to be underused
though because it's been supplanted by
RZ but did you know Riz before this
story no and I never heard of the word
and I don't know if that makes me like
really out of it does the jargon or like
Oxford kind of is using a word that
isn't the word of the year like that
it's not the word of the year it's very
very Niche people really don't use it
it's just like a slang word that exists
but it hasn't been like um assimilated
into language in the way that a lot of
playing words have it doesn't make you
in the no it's kind of like a crazy
thing yeah cuz the other options for
word of the year were
situationship oh God I hate that
word cringe yeah
Swifty that's not a that would have just
been like embarrassing if they chose
that and thirsty seeming and the other
word is prompt which would have been
used because of AI like that you have to
give a prompt it's a
stretch I feel like AI would have been a
better word of year I want to ask you
okay so tell me if you know these like
current hot slay words okay mid like
midlevel average yes used to insult or
degrade something of an opposing opinion
label labeling it as average or poor
poor quality okay yeah that's pretty his
new girl is mid that's pretty literal I
can get behind it simp simp is like when
you're being like kind of like desperate
and thirsty like sing over someone like
I wide open but you're kind of being a
loser about it when someone does way too
much for a person that they like yeah
you're being a loser trip drip with a D
um is that like when you have swagger
like you kind of when something is very
cool like it can be used to describe an
outfit or an accessory like oh look at
that drip look at that Swagger yes I'm
correct no but it's more of like a
physical
thing one thing is a drip no like you
would be describing something physical
where Swagger I think is more
personality oh I think of swagger also
as physical so what I'm thinking I just
didn't articulate it but I am thinking
of the same thing yes three for three
bet bet bet that's
like I I think of it literally as you
know like that's true Bet On It Like no
oh uh bet like almost like the truth
like yes yes yeah an expression that
means I agree great bet yeah
all right let's do one more I feel like
you either know this one for sure or you
don't cap cap like uh no cap versus cap
like uh I'm calling a lid like
like I'm calling a lid like cap like
period period no it means lying like No
Cap Jack you look gorgeous today no cap
No Lie yeah and then if somebody says
something you're like yeah sure you're
like okay cap you they say like that
okay cap yeah like cap okay do more do
more I'm I'm learning a lot shees
shees of course
shees
like wof no it's like when you're really
impressed shees but you have to be
impressed it can't be like something
amazed or impressed it can't be like
sheesh I'm not going in that Lake no
that's like how old Jewish people would
use shees but now the young cool people
are saying she they say it like that
they do okay I've never heard that
um you're definitely not going to know
NPC someone who doesn't think for
themselves but what does it stand for so
NPC is a type of live that people do and
so you'll come across someone's live and
they're like pretending to be a doll
it's so stupid okay but I like that
someone who's who doesn't think for
themselves
busing
busen I actually don't know you should
just start using it like when
something's really good like these
potato chips are busting I love that I
love that um that word is busing I think
we got all of them The Wheels on the
busing go round and round round and
round round that's my
busing um so Riz Riz is the word of the
year and and it's not and it's not I'm
so glad you brought that up yeah do I
have a question for you do do you think
that you have
Riz Charisma yes I do I know I do okay I
do I know
it by the way everything's coming up
roses that's Charisma for sure by the
way we need to talk about something that
happened last week no we don't what cuz
everybody saying that I don't know how
to do crosy that you didn't do crosy
when you said we had a whole ation about
how I love doing crosseyed and then I
did it and people were like you're not
doing it so maybe I okay let me do it
you actually like I I know you could do
crossy I would like I would go to bat
for you bet she can do crosy bet bet and
those cross No Cap No Cap those cross
eyeses are
busting my cros eyes are bsing but you
have to show everyone because you
actually you got too excited you didn't
do it okay okay ready now I'm like
nervous like maybe I'm not doing it
ready you are
I think that was it I think I think
those cross eyes were busting my cross
eyes were busing now what else is busing
is that our show is not nearly over
because we have deer toasters and we
have an update an upate start with the
update or end with the update it ends
with upate start because now you got me
titillated so we had a bride who wrote
in recently about her mom's boyfriend
coming to the and we had told her like
it sounded like she was being like a
little selfish like we understand
haven't been together for so long and
you're grieving your dad but like you do
want your mom to be happy at a day
that's really important to her and I was
really curious if she like vehemently
was just going to ignore us and disagree
hey Jackson lard I was the wenie bride
who didn't want her mom to bring a date
to my wedding since my dad had passed I
realized I was a problem hi it's me I
ended up telling my mom her man was more
than welcome they danced and had a great
time together they have since broken up
but I do not regret inviting him since
she had such a great great time and a
friend to be with all night thank you
guys for being so honest and giving me
the sisterly advice that I needed I just
got chills thank you for being a
self-aware queen who's open to feedback
yeah yeah and I'm glad that your mom had
a fun night dancing the night
away me too and hopefully you put them
at the end of the picture so you could
crap them out I doubt you put him in the
picture the boyfriend you you don't put
the boyfriend see the thing is you do
something nice for someone it makes you
feel good yeah and you we all win even
though they broke up like it doesn't
matter yeah it's some even at a wedding
you just want a dancing partner even if
you're not even in a relationship like
you bring a friend like you want to have
someone to dance with yeah especially at
your daughter's wedding now our next
submission is maybe one of the biggest
red flags I've ever experienced in toast
hory ooh okay the other night while my
husband and I were in the bathroom
getting ready for bed he was sitting on
the side of the tub and I was naked and
then he blurted out it makes me so sad
that you won't always have this good of
a
body my heart broke instantly and long
story short we just went to bed
completely silent I'm literally 21 I go
to the gym daily I have yet to have kids
obviously you literally don't even need
to explain you and your body obviously
but I'm probably at my Peak but like
really maybe I'm wrong for being so hurt
by that comment or maybe he's just an
ass help well first of all husband 21
that's young I I didn't realize that
when I was reading this the first time
was this her husband she said yeah and
he sits on the edge of the tub while she
bathes she didn't say she was in the
bath but she said he was sitting on the
side of the tub and I was naked so I
assume she was in the tub immersed in
water like I feel just feel like a tub
should be U time oh really Ben comes in
when I'm in the tub all the time oh
really yeah like I like to talk and I
sometimes need him to bring me
pretzels I guess I guess I just take me
time where I can get it the idea also
Ben is always stealing my body wash so I
scream because he needs to go get it for
me from the shower oh yeah sometimes I
do need something brought but we're not
having conversation but also you take
longer baths than I do so I'm not okay
regardless standing on the wrong part I
don't think it's weird that her husband
would keep her company not weird but
just like get out of my face for a
second get the out of my face ho
yeah so this is a bad
comment but I do think no it's bad no
it's bad but I I think that sometimes
like men can be very immature and yes
maybe at 21 he thinks oh I want you to
look like this forever but then he will
hopefully if he's like a good decent man
with depth like when he sees you get
pregnant and give birth to his children
he appreciate that body even more like I
think there's a chance that this is like
a very shallow nasty thing to say but
it's also just could be like naive and
he doesn't even know what's waiting for
him cuz I've seen so many you know like
reals those corny poetic reals about
like men who talk about how like they
appreciate their wife's bodies every
stretch mark every curve like it brought
them their family it's a vessel which it
gives them it gives life to their
children those breasts like I think that
perhaps he could mature with age and
that he won't actually always feel this
way forever but it's just a dumb
thing to say no and I do think you
should like talk to him about a why it's
hurtful B like to know that it's wrong
just so that sort of mentality doesn't
stay you know yeah like I I do think I
could definitely agree with you and see
it like being chocked up to these are
two really young people and like young
people say dumb things and years later
they realize how wrong they were but I
do think planting the seed now being
like why this was hurtful and why it's
wrong and why it's damaging like is
important in in terms of growth yeah I
agree you should say something and you
could also be like I wish you would look
like that way forever makes me sad that
you won't yeah you big ugly turd
sometimes just an eye for an
eye leaves us all blind as we should be
because if I can't see neither can you
half
blind true it was only ever one
eye it was only ever one eye so why
should you have two and I have
one I agree not in my world Boop what if
I just what if I just scoop that little
eye right out and what if I took it for
myself and now I have two and you have
one and you're cross-eyed with two
different
eyes okay ready for our third and final
one this is funny hey Jackson leard I am
dating a total PE jom and we recently
exchanged gifts for our anniversary as
one of the gifts he gave me a purse that
is 100% fake Dior I knew it instantly
because of the packaging and we are
college students and a real bag would
have just cost way too much I was
grateful but mentioned nothing of the
fakeness and neither did he I am not at
all a snob who needs a real designer but
I'm just not a designer girly I prefer
simple pieces and I do feel cringe
wearing a designer fake designer right
item because I just never cared about
labels do I say anything I am not mad at
all and he gave me plenty of amazing
gifts but I lightly cringe when I see
the bag and I just don't know if he
thinks that it's real I think it's oh
sorry I just don't know if he thinks
it's real slinks I think it's real right
does it even matter help a girly out
who's non-confrontational but would feel
better if it was not an unspoken fact
that he gifted me a fake bag yeah that's
really awkward also because you need to
make sure he doesn't get it something
like that ever again because you don't
like it like there if you are someone
who like is fine with a fake that's who
cares and that you would love the bag
like yeah who cares but if he thinks
he's slayed
the gift Department like he needs to
know like I'm fine you don't need to get
me a new gift like it's this is fine but
like going forward I don't want fake
bags this isn't my style no but she
doesn't even want designer bags like she
says it's not my style right you need to
find a way to communicate that even
designer bags like without making him
feel bad about his gift you need to let
like a bunch of time pass so it's not
like so fresh but there's just an
element of this that's like actually
really sweet like he thinks he got her a
your bag course or does he or does does
he think that he like found a really
good fake and that he
slayed I don't know men like don't know
about counterfeit stuff you know I they
do they have their own I mean if he's
into like you know their's counterfeit
jerseys yeah yeah yeah yeah maybe thinks
he like pulled a fast one over but like
you would obviously think like how did
my college age boyfriend who's on a
budget buy me a $3,000 Dior bag like I
guess you could come at it like
really um ignorantly and be like I feel
like you spend too much on this bag like
I know how much this bag love we should
return it I know how much this bag costs
like yeah we should return it and then
if he admit like oh no babe it's fake
and and then but then how do you you
should say well still I don't want I
don't want designer and I don't want
fake playing dumb is my absolute
favorite thing to do yeah no like it's
it's too much babe let's let's go back
to the store and return it yeah where'd
you get it
again the
mall yeah yeah play Dum love that
you but you should let him know because
you don't want him to keep doing this
that's really the issue it's not it's
not the one bag you can have any
everyone gets a gift they don't like and
you just put it on the Shelf but it's
about going forward one if he was
conned right right right and two like
you don't want him to keep getting gifts
of this elk it's like so sweet it is
sweet he sounds like so cute I'm not mad
unless he like was trying to buy her a
fake bag and passing it off is real like
there's so many different combinations
of how I know what does he know you know
and like what is he trying to think you
know right was he taking advantage of or
is he taking advantage of you and your
kindness and your generousness of spirit
you got to say that the gift was too
much and you want to return it that's
the only way forward
here it's simply the only way yeah you
have to find out how much he
knows but you also have to course
correct yeah you have a lot of work to
cut out for you I don't envy you we we
do dear toasters every Wednesday and if
you ever want to write in about
something that's going on in your life
we will of course always keep it
Anonymous and you can do so by emailing
dear toasters gmail.com or you can go to
our website the toast podcast.com
there's a little submission box when you
scroll down also completely Anonymous we
will help you out and if we have helped
you out in recent weeks months or years
and you have an update for us like did
you take our advice did it work did you
not take our advice did you wish you did
don't leave The Toasters hanging we love
doing updates thank you to the girl who
wrote in today with her update you can
also send us an email dear toasters at
gmail.com with an update just put update
in the uh what I was just thinking cuz I
was like I know we had a good title for
the episode when we were talking and I'm
like trying to remember it because I
thought you were about to make fun of me
cuz I said the word update like 50 times
in one sentence no no no I was just
thinking of what today's title is and I
remembered and I remembered and it's so
funny let me think did you not have that
feeling when we were saying something
like oh that's the title A plus b plus C
equals D oh oh so good okay what what is
yours those cross are
busing that's the title have a great day
everyone thank you so much for listening
to the toast L Morning Show where we
deal with the fast stories so need to
know every Monday Friday on YouTube
watching on YouTube please subscribe and
give this video a thumbs up we're also
podcast and podcast be sptify
leave five star you better beautiful
sing and wickedly talented we
are have a great day happy hump day
don't forget to hump someone you love
bye love you
bye